Speaker 1: Let's go next to John
from Sacramento. John, welcome.
John from Sacramento, you're on the air.
And last chance for John from Sacramento.
You're not muted. So I'm guessing you
have the wrong microphone selected in
discord. One last shot at fixing that. All
right. John from Sacramento, not working.
Let's go to Chris from Philly. Chris,
I know you're going to save us with a properly
configured microphone, right, my friend?
Speaker 3: Hopefully.
Speaker 1: All right. That's not bad.
Speaker 3: So I've been waiting
to do this for a long time.
Speaker 1: Chris Black Chris, are you
saying you're you're identifying yourself
as a black man? Is that what you're saying?
Speaker 3: Oh, yes, sir. Okay. Well, thank you.
One by one. One thing I have a pet peeve with
Republicans right now is with the whole Roe v
Wade thing and no one's really sitting there
saying nothing about Sharia law anymore.
Speaker 1: Oh, right. In other words, let me
see if I understand your point. You're saying
they used to talk about, oh, they want to take
over American law with Sharia law. But now that
they're trying to succeeding to some degree at
taking over American civil law with Christianity,
now they don't care about that anymore.
Speaker 3: Factual.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Well, listen, Adam
Kinzinger, I talked about this on the show.
Adam Kinzinger is calling I don't know if
you saw Lauren Boebert recently said she's
tired of separation of church and state. And Adam
Kinzinger, who's a Republican, called it Christian
Taliban, which is exactly what it is.
Speaker 3:
At the end of the day, I guess you could say she
saved again after she got exposed. Right.
Speaker 1: Right. Yeah. No, it's great. These
people are hypocrites and they're dangerous.
But the really scary thing, Chris, is
if they do well in November, all bets are off
as to how far they can go with this. They could
really do some serious damage to the country.
Speaker 3: Without a doubt. All right, my friend.
Anything else for Angela? No, that was it.
Speaker 1: All right. Chris from Philly,
thanks for the call.
Speaker 3: No problem.